we are living in the internet age why
don't people get this more and faster I
mean because people look backwards
instead of looking forward 90% of people
default into looking behind them instead
of looking ahead of them it's the human
psyche I think most people are scared of
change and they look for negatives yeah
I don't know just so happy you're part
of team but it's literally something
about that theme that was so perfect for
me
morning vlog 9 a.m. here in Stockholm
gorgeous nice background I'm with a
bunch of good-looking men here we're
about to go some meetings super excited
about the day getting a lot done yes yes
oh thank you very much here's my good
friend our tech startup
yeah you guys might have saw that
happened 100 Independence Day today
fill-ins hundred yes from who from
Russia I thought I know my history
anyway see in a second a bunch of
meetings come a keynote couple recaps
before we go into the day gonna give you
some edits here babban
number one pop it fully and in full full
edit mode the dollar eighty strategy is
crushing I want you to start deploying
the 18 cent strategy you're gonna drop a
dollar eighty a day two cents at a time
nine top posts times 10 different
hashtags every day and that will
massively build up your audience
Shane everybody wants to talk the way to
win is to listen and then contribute
everybody wants to put a picture of
themselves like you looking cool running
but I looked at your social and just
like 99% of people watching nobody's
listening yet that's okay that's not
discouraging to me nobody listened to me
at first either let me say it one more
time for over a year nobody watched my
shows on YouTube the way to be
discovered is to either put out great
content have one great piece of content
go viral and then everyone
Discover's you or become part of the
community you're gonna get exposure
you're gonna get some followers
you're gonna contribute but you're also
gonna learn because you're gonna watch
90 pieces of content doing well on
Instagram which is then going to inspire
and help you strategize the content that
you yourself are gonna put out on
Instagram that's a good use of three
hours and I'm getting tweeted deemed
emailed like crazy when I taste
something like the 2017 flip challenged
and I know brings value to you an
amazing thing is happening people are
blown away that one of the best
strategies in social media is being
social understand it watch this clip
actually you know what I got nothing
else to say get that in let's go on to
the rest of the day
exactly and that tastes like actually
doing it exactly exactly Suzanne you
heard of it all right because you have
friends that have been working in place
for 15 months still haven't done
anything
exactly so like making coffee and I like
putting things out for that boss and
that's it and it's just incredible and
like I say a year went past all saints
and hundreds of build the processes from
the ground up I said to Joe no look I
don't actually think I'm like learning
anymore they can just following
processes now and within a month I'm on
grunty and running like the biggest
spend the London office heart and pretty
much like autonomously as well and and
just like dodge don't know whatever
happened anyway yeah hey laughs it's so
it's so good and like and that's the way
you learn and it's the way you develop
it like and I'd say like I have a friend
a co-worker financier for other agencies
and they don't do anything for two years
three years whether they in two or three
years like a game changes exactly how
you loved it so much this is there is no
substitute for doing that virtually I'd
rather you know oh the other thing the
biggest mistake that business makers the
business owners make or companies make
is when they don't let somebody do
something for two or three years they
don't know if the person's good same
paid for two or three years they not
done anything productive and then they
get exposed once they hit the field
what's the bad strategy to me it's like
it's offense versus defense for me the
reason we put you in that position and
everybody in that position is to to we
believe and if unfortunate doesn't work
out quicker to learn you know you're not
gonna know through good at skiing by
watching videos you're gonna learn by
getting on it on there and finding out
yeah they're waiting right thank you
very much I'll see you later thank you
thank you
hello Sebastian Sebastian your pleasure
Thanks yeah what do you want me to do
let's go this way yeah so what's up Gary
how you doing life is good man I've been
following you since two years back thank
you and I mean it's crazy when I when I
saw your stand and the vibe you send it
out there to do your audience and
highest felt like this is the thing I
need to put some energy on I appreciate
it you know I guess I didn't know
nothing about filming so I went out
filming with my cell phone and trying
we're buying my fate and my class
basically loved it and I got into this
selling content for companies yes so
I've been working for two years got a
little bit bigger camera yes got some
people around me that's gonna
potentially be surrounding yourself with
good-looking people
good smart smart straddles matter to me
I get it
I mean it's thanks to you man that makes
my heart happy brother and well I was
the seed but you nurtured it right yeah
so when people like you helped you did
it like thanks to you I'm like I'm doing
it for everybody I'm doing it for the
for the culture for the community I'm
doing it but the people that grab it and
do something about it you know I'm just
creating the conversation I'm I'm
forcing the conversation in the way I do
it down people's throats but I'm
fascinated by the people that listen and
watch and are like yeah listen and watch
and say you him but most importantly
listen and watch and then go do
something that's the more interesting
part and the reason I talk so much about
patience is a lot of people watch me
start something and then give up ten
days later ten days silly I think the
next step is to not overly think about
the next step you know like those cliche
things like if you want to get to the
top of mountain it's like one step at a
time I believe in that like I think the
biggest things that cripples a guy like
you two years in starting to build
something you know you get a little
taste and you want more right that's
always a dangerous part I'm very scared
usually at year two three four of a
little bit of momentum that's where a
lot of people try to go to
ask them break the whole thing get a
little fancy get either content or too
hungry it's about staying in the middle
and remembering what got you there I
mean look I'm a great example of it you
know I always want people to watch me
carefully like I'm winning I've gotten
fancy and I'm getting less fancy like
I'm sure I'm like you know as good
things are happening for me I'm trying
to go more Trident trio as the light
gleams I'm trying to go more into being
and operate I'm gonna speak less next
year I'm gonna operate more I'm gonna do
more HR and see my people like I think
it's just important to I don't think
about what's next ever like of course
I'm thinking every day about what I want
to do that's going to help me win but I
don't think of it as next I think people
look at it like you know and I just look
at it like and so I think the best way
to have something happened that's going
to bring you value is remembering what
got you there what got you to where you
are right now is you got motivated you
took a camera out from your phone and
you started doing and then good started
happening and I think a lot of people
start overthinking and putting too much
pressure on themselves for what's next I
see a lot of companies and people go
from zero to a million dollars and then
stick at a million for five or six years
and they beat themselves up and I always
remind them that that's incredible but
more importantly I remind them that the
reason you're not growing is you changed
when you got from zero to a million got
it and so for me as I get more Fame and
recognition and opportunity I'm
crippling down on humility and patience
I think the guy that or girl that has my
position is always in the best position
I think when you're selling something
new it's less early bird gets the worm
your second Mouse gets the cheese
there's a lot of people that don't want
to work with us because I'm the one that
most upset them and it's the second or
third yeah yeah I mean I get enough for
what I'm looking for right yeah you know
it's all relative right by running an
actual good business yeah you know I buy
yes of course of course
thanks bang I wish you well and you may
leave then please yeah I'll be very nice
the basketball team I'm a real fan cuz I
am a one yet yeah I'm bet at this point
babban babban This Is It this is Babbitt
this is a you've been waiting for this I
know you've been want you to take a
picture this is as the hoard is oh this
horse lamp is alright everybody get bad
in some love what am i good
we will no problem I don't think this is
as generational as people think I think
this is more psychology than it is you
know none of the four people sitting in
this room right well the baboon's
younger but the three and you're pretty
elderly oh yeah oh that's right I bring
everybody into these podcasts I like to
break the walls and visualize for you
everybody who's listening look the three
of us didn't like 35 okay look you know
it's not about how old you I'm 42 and I
feel more curious and more understanding
of the culture in the game than plenty
of people that are 18 I think it's a
mindset and so it's a very interesting
time to be alive there's so much
opportunity and I'm excited to be a part
of it I only want one thing for people
that I have really outside of health the
only thing I wish for people is them to
love what they do as much as I do when I
do new podcasts or new video shows I
love reading the comments of the
audience that don't know me inevitably
5% of the audience will leave a comment
that refers to drugs if they want to be
really snarky they'll say I you know
cocaine ritalin you know they they think
that I'm on something and I always reply
because I've never tried smoking a
cigarette let alone done adderall I
reply with grat the end so they'll say
cocaine and I'll reply gratitude I'm so
grateful that I do what I love everyday
and what I love for clarification is
just being an entrepreneur playing the
challenges the risk the excitement I
have tremendous energy because it builds
momentum when you're doing what you want
to be doing for a long period of time it
builds momentum I didn't have the same
energy in school I hated school I was
optimistic I was high energy that's my
DNA but not like this this is now a
supernova
because now I'm 20
into being in my zone the the breath of
fresh air the exhale I had on the first
day that I worked at my dad's liquor
store like worked like there was no more
school ever again
that was incredible just posted
something on Instagram for the mindset
I'm getting more and more intrigued by
mindset because I used to think of it as
fluffy like self-help and now I think it
more as strategy what's your strategy in
life somebody asked me on Instagram
after I posted a scary if the mindset
has been skewed how can you bring it
back and I answered with by surrounding
yourself with people who have the
mindset you aspire to my friends please
understand that mindset is controllable
in the same way that all our opinions
are controllable the key is to add more
people with optimism and cut people with
negativity it's very very simple now
it's very hard to cut people with
pessimism cynicism and negativity when
they are the people that are the closest
to you parents siblings spouse but the
bottom line is if you're asking the
question I'm gonna give you the answer
the answer is add more people with
positivity and optimism and cut people
with pessimism and cynicism who you
surround yourself matters what content
you consume matters I basically
suffocate myself for a long period of my
time and created an environment that was
based on offense and optimism and now I
know no different please do the same for
you make that move mold and I mean mold
your mindset by what you consume and
with whom you consume it how are you
first of all I miss so inspired by the
whole Carriere everything you've done in
and I mean your social work as well how
do you do to stay in shape mentally or
physically if physically physically I
travel with a trainer
yeah which was a huge commitment I made
and I try to watch what I eat but I work
out every single day yes seven days a
week I'm in a gym that's
because I actually saw before you know
so you had something in your mess
talking I love it yeah I eat those too
but then it just makes me work for an
extra 20 minutes yeah I love it but it's
funny because they're actually showing
up with it yes in my armpit - yes if you
hold your hand like this and we have two
of them so I take one of the donuts in
my hand and you squeeze this one really
tight in your hand okay the tight and
now I take this point invisibly and that
place it back into your hand
did you felt anything I'm gonna have two
Donuts oh yeah
if I pull out one - how many do you have
left I'm supposed to have two but I'm a
funny feeling I don't open like so crazy
right what do you think mom something
they're all in yeah yeah I understand
you know honestly honestly I honestly
that's an interesting observation
I really think to be successful it has
to be sometimes too much to be
successful when everybody else wants it
to it has to be 110 percent not 97 and
everybody wants to be 97 and what people
don't realize is I don't think it even
takes a hundred I think it's a hundred
and two like like I dream strategy
[Music]
working on new ideas different things
creating content behind the screen or I
guess I get it it's such an interesting
and I remember Mara Dona in 86 with the
punch yeah I watched that game and I so
there's things I've always remembered in
the 94 World Cup was in the US the my
soccer I'm setting up for the blog that
my sausage feels zero double zero but
I'm competitive and I'm trying I'm
basically trying to mentally will a
miracle right now so basically the goal
is to get
go between the legs if you do that up
coup of the other person we're gonna
play like one sir understood yes there's
almost like wait a minute
would it be better for me to have the
bigger bag oh and nutmeg is a direct win
[Applause]
I'm a strategy bum
I'm not getting nutmegs on the first
good minute all right what nothing be
careful be careful I'm already feeling
extremely accomplished
oh it's like oh you know
I didn't even realize I lost that was
amazing man thank you this is great
super pissed about the Nutmeg I didn't
realize I lost okay I'll catch you guys
later bulky so very excited to be here
you understand
what we're living through we're living
through a race we're about to run a
marathon any technology technology will
eat up every aspect of everything
always and forever it's how it works the
book stores were first met it was people
that owned taxi services then it was the
hotel industry with Airbnb but it will
keep going the biggest TV networks in
the world now then there's OTT this will
keep going everything just cuz we have
big contracts with the biggest companies
in the world
what's that contract worth when that
company is not alive this is real and so
we're about to run a marathon and the
reason I stress on you could be good at
that is not because I think that's the
end all be all but you have no chance to
be good at AR and VR and machine
learning and cryptocurrency and
everything else that's coming next if
you did not ground yourself in this you
can't run a 40 mile marathon right now
on the spot if you haven't been on the
treadmill for the last six months and
running little mini races to prepare and
if you are not adapting this
psychologically first religion first and
then becoming a practitioner you need to
be the architect the general contractor
and the plumber because if you don't you
will use and so I thank you thank you
started just based off based off of your
stuff right started live-streaming
myself making a hip-hop demo every
single day because that's what I'm into
so i'm on twitch now yeah that up over
the last month I was like like no one's
doing that much in the creative the
music section right now why don't I like
leave that up so I've been doing that
I've seen like new baby steps even for a
small artist like me right one one month
from starting
I see SoundCloud plays every single day
now go from ten to twenty one hundred
hundred and fifty just climbing up
stoked I just want to say thanks if I
could give you a hug your brother really
appreciate everything you do
[Laughter]
miss it when you're in time so glad you
guys came yes thank you so much for
everything you've done friend I think so
much appreciate thank you he's looking
up to you he's a very special kid yeah
he really is yes he really is I've been
here before yeah I've been here before
I am so glad you guys are here this is
such a pleasure for me dunk look who I
found the family is finally together I
can do this I got that
[Music]
this was that was symbolic
that was super symbolic I felt good
about that there were there was
literally something about that scene
that was so perfect for me me through
you stuck yes she was very senior in
this market yeah of course great to see
you the fact that I would have time to
look at something and think about the
back I mean I don't have time I don't
have time to celebrate my good friends
doing good am i doing spending time
trying to drag somebody it's such a bad
life that I now when I read his daddy
helped him he sucks he [ __ ] a cocky
[ __ ]
I feel bad I'm like that's you're using
that as the energy of the output of your
life you've absolutely lost and the
other thing and I apologize
the truth wins at the end I mean nice I
did a sneaker I got killed behind the
scenes he thinks he's a big shot
nobody's gonna move gonna buy a sneaker
k-swiss who gives them garyvee what does
he think he's famous until my sneaker
sold out in a day then what the truth is
gonna win either they're right where
you're right but you're too important to
spend it on them the 5% of people that
you actually need to win with mentally
never believe that stuff the fun isn't
only the 5% of people that you need to
win with in the world are are not paying
attention to a headline in Business
Insider
I started realizing it started you know
what started happening I started getting
more trolls but more Warren Buffett and
the rod like winners and I said wait a
minute
well if that's happened at the end of
the day it's gonna be the results at the
end of May it's gonna be the results
nothing else nothing else so to me just
because people are booing your team when
you're losing in the second quarter down
by ten as long as you win the game at
the end you win I know my man you're
gonna [ __ ] it either listen here's the
best part I know you're good it makes it
makes me so happy man look like my whole
life has been that I got made fun of for
launching a website instead of a second
liquor store I got made fun of for doing
a YouTube show
I got a made fun of a lot for investing
in Facebook and Twitter 2007 my
financial advisors were upset
this is stupid what if it goes to zero
I'm like but what if it doesn't
everybody's on the defense my man you've
done something yeah man and more
importantly merit vote and by the way
it's not that you and I are cool we may
be wrong they may be right but when
they're writing from the stands they
have to wait for the game to end I mean
look if somebody came along and tweaked
the MLM network marketing model and made
a cleaner and less [ __ ] it's real by
the way it happened it's called seamless
and uber like affiliate like it works
incentivized works you can make you can
make anybody do anything if your
incentive I can get everybody naked here
right now 100% man what's your price -
uh nope
now be careful I'll tell you why I agree
I agree but I'll watch it oh wait a
minute I'll demo you I want you to go I
want you to get butt naked right here
right now let's play this out for a
second in theory what do you think how
much like you agree that I can get you
butt naked right okay
in my head I was right so let's play how
much money do you think it would cost
right now for you to literally go right
there literally right there right now
and get butt-naked what do you think
like seriously and be careful because
I'm in a weird mood and I'm looking to
get 10 million views on this episode
what do you think he's from Pensacola I
[Laughter]
swear on my kids I might pay you the
number so I need you to really be
careful and really because this is where
you could lose all the equity if you go
back on it what do you think it would
cost for you to get 100% naked right
here right now what do you think I'm
trying to think like this for myself how
much would cost you to shave your head
no no shave the head shave your head
that's it yeah I mean that's an
interesting one you're fine what about
for you
how much so how much okay I'll pay that
right now Sheamus $100 right now right
now let's look we're gonna shave his
head let's how do we get like do can you
go into is there a razor in Europe you
in for Finland's hundredth birthday $200
that's done but now they have a razor
babban get on it leave this leave this
right here I mean there's gotta be
either it's either in our hotel room go
to go downstairs and find out they can
just shave it shaving cream cuz I want
to be good for him goodness there's 100%
guy vlog we're shaving us heads $100
Abin recording yourself
Oh even better all right we'll find
everything in to update the [ __ ]
sweetie
so like a few minutes ago Gary asked me
how much it would cost me to get naked
in the middle of the bar
I said 25,000 he then asked everyone how
much to shave their head
the guy next to me set a hundred bucks
gate I told her to go out and buy a
razor I have a really weird question is
there like a pharmacy or anything open
around here that I can beat clippers to
cut someone's hair with okay I just want
to say that if I was in New York this
would have been handled in about six
minutes but because I'm in Stockholm
everything closes like seven is
providing a little bit more difficult
how's it going I um
do you guys have a razors like a in
theory I needed to cut my hair off no
would would there be anywhere around
here that would have that at this time
no thank you all right guess we're
adding another L in balance column now I
have to go tell Gary I couldn't find it
not gonna go over well which means I
might end up having to take all my
clothes off in the middle of the bar
ready we are we all will go loudly very
upset babiness failed Lev Levin babban
zero you're very fortunate or
unfortunate fortunate I want to do it
for Finland you know 100 100 we should
shave a hundred in his head
[Music]
you
[Music]